What if you could see the market before
it happens? Not through a crystal ball,
but through highresolution data. In the
next 4 minutes, I will show you how to
stop losing money to BTC traps and start
trading like the top 1% of institutional
defenders. The BTC market is a war zone.
95% of retail traders are just liquidity
for whales. You lose because of three
things: information asymmetry, emotional
instability, and noise. You're bringing
a laptop to a supercomput fight. It's
time to upgrade your hardware. Enter
Trap Defense BTC. Our ecosystem is built
on three pillars. First, the Trap
Defense Engine. It detects whale dumps
and liquidation cascades in real time.
Second, Gemini visual storytelling. We
turn dry onchain data into intuitive
news stories you can understand in
seconds. Third, Dr. Grock, our AI
psychologist, stays by your side 24/7,
monitoring your mental state to prevent
revenge trading. We don't just give you
data, we give you a bulletproof mind.
We've seen our members survive the most
brutal market crashes without a single
liquidation. This isn't just an academy,
it's a survival protocol. Our plan start
at just $69, a fraction of what a single
trap could cost you. The choice is
yours. Stay in the dark or see the
traps. Click below to secure your
capital.